eran dos procesiones una rumbo a las
afueras de la casa blanca otra la de los
comercios que se reunían para certificar
la victoria de joe biden en las
elecciones
el telón va a abrir presidente downtown
el mandatario había pedido a grandes
multitudes que se congregarán este
miércoles para su discurso una rara
intervención en los últimos días de su
mandato pero con un mensaje repetido
todos aquí no queremos que nos roben la
elección por un demócrata izquierdista
ha empoderado una elección robada por la
noticias falsas eso es lo que han hecho
y eso es lo que están haciendo no nos
rendiremos
nunca concederemos eso no va a pasar uno
no concede cuando hay robo involucrado
un discurso incendiario que termino
siendo la antesala de la que iba a ser
la ratificación de los votos del colegio
electoral en el congreso y que tendría
un desenlace nunca visto es un trámite
que en esta ocasión se veía interrumpido
por el anuncio de varios congresistas
republicanos para pedir una auditoría
estos legisladores se amparaban en las
denuncias sin pruebas de un supuesto
fraude electoral en los comicios de
noviembre las miradas sobre el
vicepresidente de mike pence antes en su
discurso el presidente trump había
afirmado de manera errónea que pence
tenía la capacidad para no aceptar los
votos electorales algo que el propio
vicepresidente desmintió en un
comunicado afuera la multitud seguía con
la hoja de ruta de la protesta y se
dirigía al congreso pero trump no los
acompañaba como él había prometido
empezó el caos la multitud llegó a las
escaleras del capitolio
adentro se suspendía la votación los
legisladores se ponían bajo resguardo
algunos dentro de sus propios despachos
los seguidores de champ ya estaban por
el salón de las estatuas y luego dentro
del mismo senado el congreso asediado un
escenario dantesco inédito en la
historia de eeuu